frantic search and rescue efforts are underway in
India after one of the worst rail collisions in
recent history more than 280 people were killed
and 900 were wounded in the crash involving two
passenger trains and a freight train this morning
there's fear the death toll will climb as Rescuers
sift through the wreckage in the Eastern State
of Odessa the state's chief minister has declared
today a day of mourning Rainey in ascencio
has more as Rescuers pull in from the wreckage
this man is lucky to be alive the
less fortunate pulled out unmoving
by bystanders the dead laid out next to
the tracks it's the latest in a string
of trained tragedies in India which have
claimed more than one thousand lives in
the past two decades this surge of wounded and
dazed victims overwhelming small local hospitals
something when everything in the train started
flying around said this Survivor people fell all
over each other as Dawn broke search and rescue
teams ramped up their efforts with sniffer dogs
and cutting equipment to find and free the living
and the dead still trapped in the mangled Heap
prime minister Narendra Modi briefed in
New Delhi will visit the crash site and
the injured today and faces fresh criticism of
Decades of government neglect of India's vast 40
000 Mile Rail Network and its tragic consequences
for CBS Saturday morning Remy inocencio London